SHE IS THE REAL HERO.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S TIME FOR.
>> GUTFELD INDUSTRIAL HYGIENE
CORPORATION IN CONJUNCTION WITH
SELF ASSEMBLING ELVES PRESENTS
HOW TO BE A JOURNALIST WITH YOUR
HOST, BRAD PITT.
>> Greg: HI, I'M YOUR HOST,
BRAD PITT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT ROLLING STONE,
ALSO KNOWN AS CRAP.
THE ONCE GREAT NOW PILE OF WET
GARBAGE PUBLISHED A STORY
CLAIMING AN OKLAHOMA HOSPITAL
WAS SO OVERWHELMED BY PATIENTS
OVERDOSING ON HORACE D WORMER
MEDICATION THAN ACTUAL GUNSHOT
VICTIMS WERE STUCK OUTSIDE IN
AMBULANCES WAITING FOR BEDS.
MEANWHILE, HORSES FULL OF WORMS
HAD TO WAIT OUTSIDE BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T WEARING MASKS.
WITH A STORY THAT SOUNDS THIS ON
THE NOSE YOU WOULD ASSUME ANY
COMPETENT JOURNALIST WOULD REACH
OUT TO THE HOSPITALS BEFORE THEY
WRITE ABOUT IT.
AFTER ALL, THESE MODERN
FACILITIES HAVE PHONES AND FACTS
MACHINES AND CARRIER PIGEONS AT
A BRAND-NEW THING WE LIKE TO
CALL EMAIL.
HAVING TWO OR MORE SOURCES,
VERIFYING INFORMATION BEFORE YOU
PRESENTED AS FACT, OH, WHERE'S
THE FUN IN THAT?
THIS IS ROLLING STONE, WHOSE
READERSHIP STILL HASN'T USED
THEIR AOL FREE TRIAL CITIES.
IT'S THE WEEKEND AT BERNIE'S
VERSION OF JOURNALISM.
A DEAD PRODUCT PROPPED UP BY
VIRTUE SIGNALING AND
INCOMPETENTS WHO BELIEVE IN
SANTA THINK.
THE WRITING IS SO PAINFUL THEY
SHOULD CHANGE THEIR NAME TO
KIDNEY STONE.
STEPHEN KING HAS NOTHING ON
THESE TURDS WHEN IT COMES TO
FICTION.
THE STORY WAS ORIGINALLY FROM
OKLAHOMA QUOTING A DOCTOR WITHIN
THE NORTHEASTERN HOSPITAL SYSTEM
DENIED ANY PATIENTS WERE TREATED
FOR ODs.
ENDED DOCTOR HADN'T WORKED AT
ONE OF THE HOSPITALS IN QUESTION
FOR MONTHS.
I HAVEN'T SEEN DENIAL OF A
STRONG SINCE THE TIME ELTON JOHN
MARRIED A WOMAN.
THERE WERE ABSOLUTELY NO
OVERDOSES RELATED TO IVERMECTIN,
NOR WERE ANY PATIENTS TURNED
AWAY DUE TO AN OVERLOAD.
APART FROM THAT DETAIL, THE
STORY CHECKED OUT JUST FINE.
AT FIRST ROLLING STONE KEPT
PUSHING THE STORY THEN RAN AN
UPDATED, NO RETRACTION.
WHEN I GOT TOO BIG TO BURY THEY
RAN A HUMILIATING CORRECTION BUT
NOT BEFORE A PILE OF LIBERAL
MAINSTREAM MEDIA FIGURES EMBRACE
THEIR PANJSHIR.
RACHEL MADDOW TWEETED ABOUT IT.
JOY REID WHO APPARENTLY STILL
HAS A JOB PROMOTING THE STORY ON
HER SHOW.
>> AND EMERGENCY ROOM IN ONE
RURAL LOCAL HOMETOWN IS
OVERWHELMED BY PEOPLE OVERDOSING
ON IVERMECTIN, THE HORSE
DEWORMING MEDICATION.
IT'S GOTTEN SO BAD GUNSHOT
VICTIMS ARE HAVING TO WAIT TO BE
TREATED.
>> Greg: GREAT JOB, JOY.
MAYBE IT'S TIME MSNBC GOT
TREATED FOR WORMS.
AFTER ALL, HOW MANY TIMES HAVE
THEIR HOSTS LOOK LIKE A HORSES
ASS?
THERE WAS A LIST OF SUCKERS WHO
BOUGHT THIS STORY FROM BUSINESS
INSIDER TO THE GUARDIAN.
SOMEONE FROM "THE DAILY BEAST."
THERE WAS A MSNBC PRODUCER AND
SO ON.
THESE IDIOTS ARE WRONG MORE
OFTEN THEN BY TRYING TO BUTTON
UP HIS SHIRT.
WHAT'S THE LESSON HERE?
THE FAKE STORY TOOK OFF WITHOUT
ANYONE WITHIN THAT MEDIA BUBBLE
APPLYING THE BRAKES.
THEY PLACE THEIR FEET ON THE GAS
PEDAL.
FIRST OF ALL, THE MEDIA IS NOT
OUR BEST AND BRIGHTEST PEOPLE,
PRESENT COMPANY EXCLUDED OF
COURSE.
YOU FIND BETTER AND SMARTER
FOLKS IN THE FRONT ROW OF A
MIDNIGHT COCKFIGHT IN GUAM.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHOSE ONLY
CONTENT IS CLICK BAY DESIGNED TO
MAKE THEIR LEFTIST CONSUMERS
FEEL SUPERIOR, AND THAT'S WHAT
THE STORY DID.
IT GAVE THEIR PATIENTS A DOSE OF
DUMB REDNECK THERAPY, SOMETHING
TO CHAT ABOUT WHILE THE BARISTA
SCREWS UP YOUR LATTE.
ROLLING STONE WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR ONE OF THE MOST DAMAGING
HOAXES EVER, PEACE CALLED A RAPE
ON CAMPUS.
A CRIME THEY NEVER HAPPEN.
THEY GLEEFULLY RAN WITH IT.
THEY LATER RETRACTED THE STORY
AFTER THE LIVES OF THE ACCUSER
WERE RUINED FOREVER.
UVA'S REPUTATION WAS SEVERELY
TARNISHED IN AMERICAN COLLEGES
WENT INTO A FULL-BLOWN PANIC DUE
TO A MAKE-BELIEVE CAMPUS RAPE
EPIDEMIC.
YOU'D THINK THEY WOULD LEARN BUT
TO LEARN YOU HAVE TO SEVER
UNPLEASANT CONSEQUENCES.
MEANWHILE ROLLING STONE JUST GOT
A NEW EDITOR IN CHIEF FROM OF
ALL PLACES "THE DAILY BEAST."
THAT'S LIKE HIRING YOUR
BABYSITTER FROM DEATH ROW.
IT'S A BUMMER.
I GREW UP IDOLIZING
ROLLING STONE.
WHEN THE CLASH OR CHEAP TRICK
MADE THE COVER INVALIDATED MY
LIFE BECAUSE THOSE WERE MY BANDS
SO I TOLERATED THE COMMIE
LEFTISM.
NOW IT'S A MESS.
ROLLING STONE IS JOURNALISM AS
BARFING INTO AN AIR CONDITIONER
IS TO AIR CONDITIONER REPAIR.
MAYBE THEY ALWAYS SUCKED AND I
DIDN'T KNOW IT.
AFTER ALL, ROLLING STONE PANNED
LED ZEPPELIN'S FIRST TWO ALBUMS,
JIMI HENDRIX FIRST ALBUM, BLACK
SABBATH, NIRVANA, NEIL YOUNG,
THE ROLLING STONES.
NEED I GO ON.
WHY DOESN'T THIS MAGAZINE LOCKED
UP IN GITMO WHERE IT BELONGS?
PERHAPS THEY SHOULD STOP DOING
THESE -- THE MUSICAL ALTOGETHER
AND STICK TO A POLITICALLY
OWNING THE ROOMS.
HERE ARE SOME IDEAS.
TRANSGENDER RACCOON FAMILIES.
BABIES OR RABIES.
WHY YOU SHOULD NEVER TRUST WHITE
PEOPLE EXCEPT FOR US BECAUSE WE
LIKE TRACY CHAPMAN.
800-POUND MAN DIES AT HOT DOG
EATING CONTEST.
COVID SUSPECTED.
TOP 500 SONGS OF ALL TIME,
NUMBER ONE "MY HUMP" BY BLACK
EYES PEAS.
TOM HANKS HAS TEMPORARILY PASSED
AWAY.
WHY ARE THEY CALLED
AFRICAN-AMERICAN SABBATH?
FINALLY, DEWEY DEFEATS TRUMAN.
STILL MAGIC.
EMBRACE IT, ROLLING STONE.
YOUR ROLE AS A RESPECTED MUS